you know why that one stack of boxes on
cash is called shroud molotov's in set
piece out shroud has let them all pass
one two
the spot has had that name ever since
that crazy play but CS go isn't the only
game to have a shroud this call out also
spilled over into valorin over here
around these boxes is called shroud I
don't know the exact reason I just hear
a lot of people calling it shroud so
that's what I call it now you might
assume that shroud did some other crazy
[__] on these boxes but you'd be wrong
this map pissed me off it's actually not
that deep the double boxes on a sense a
site basically just looks similar to the
spot on cash and by some reports you can
actually use this call out to identify
any spot where you can give yourself a
boost so you shroud elsewhere if you
must because honestly anything's better
than a teammate who just says there
right there